you're now live chad
thank you good afternoon everybody
i would like to welcome you all to this
virtual meeting of auditing governance
committee
on the 26th of january and i'll just go
through some of the basic rules for this
meeting
at the start of the meeting we will mute
all microphones
except for mine please leave all
microphones muted
unless you are asked to speak by me
to indicate to me that you would like to
speak or propose or second emotion
please press the raise the hand symbol
in the reactions menu on your screen
these are shown on my screen in the
order that they are pressed
and i will deal with them in order
giving the appropriate officer or
counselor the opportunity to answer in
between
where necessary i will also return to
the cancer
to check that they are happy with the
response
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
the virtual meetings
all votes will be cast via a verbal
recorded vote
and names will be read out in
alphabetical or order
please state your vote clearly and
slowly when your name is read out
unmuting and muting your microphone as
necessary
please remember that to ensure full
transparency with the democratic process
this meeting is being live streamed on
the council's
youtube channel
we are in unprecedented times and i ask
you all to be patient during this
meeting
and to understand the processes and
advice
may take longer than usual right
that being said it's on with the
register of attendance
and i'll ask our classes clark this
afternoon kirsty to read out the names
and for the members to confirm their
attendance so over to you kirsty
thank you chair councillor crazy
president
councillor hackett present councillor
heppel
present councillor hudson
thank you um councillor jones has given
apologies
councillor rossi not present
thank you
no apologies for cancer rossi
and no substitute for counselor jones
right okay
thank you um we now move on to
item two confirmation in the minutes to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on 22nd september
2020 and they are pages 4 to 12.
i'll just go through and if anybody
wants to raise anything as we go through
so i'll start
at page four
page five
page six
page seven page
eight page nine
page ten page eleven
and finally page twelve right i'm happy
to propose from the chair
that those minutes are accurate uh would
anybody like to second
counselor craigie are you wishing to
second
thanks yes i will second them but i did
want to just ask a question
about the pension thing but i don't know
whether it's really um
it's i'm not doubting the minutes i'm
not questioning the minutes what i want
to do is just i would like to ask a
further question if i may
and i'll write for now okay shall we
just confirm the minutes
and then i'll come back to your point as
it's not a matter of accuracy of the
minutes okay thank you
right so kirsty if you'd like to take
the vote for the minutes please
thank you chair councillor craigie four
councillor hackett or councillor heppell
four councillor hudson falls
that's unanimous chair
thank you very much okay if if you just
like to
to very briefly make your point that you
would
it was just some i should have asked at
the time because when we had that
presentation
on the pension um it was said
that there's an annual general meeting
to which
all members of the pension scheme can go
well
i think it means all organizations not
all
members not you know george mean
pensioners
potential pensioners i just wondered who
goes
from torridge that's all i wanted to ask
and um does steve's not here i guess
we can't answer that well actually if
if kirstie could take a note david might
read her response
david might be able to respond yes yeah
i'll have to check i
saw an email about that um the last one
i actually attended
the last one that was actually a
physical meeting i attended
uh i've seen something for the virg
david you've muted yourself i'm sorry
i'd have to check sorry when the
virtual meeting is yeah thanks
thanks very much i'd like to know when
the meeting is if possible
so that i could possibly put some
input into it but that that's all thanks
very much okay
okay right thank you so if we move on to
the action list item
three um
we don't
does anybody wish to speak to this as
steve is absent at the moment
either council hudson you have your hand
up
claire would you like to come in yes
i've unmuted myself i got muted again
um yes i would like to raise this
because
we we this seems to be going on and on
and on
um safeguarding is one of the
major issues for um
compliance i feel uh with
with a local government in local
government i think we need to make sure
that we have all the protocols in place
time after time when i've attended
meetings with regard to
why safeguarding issues
have failed and there's been um
you know the mop-up sessions that they
have
it has been down to poor information
sharing
and unless we get this straight we are
still
going to be failing in that respect so i
don't think this is something that we
can just keep on saying oh well
we haven't done it yet i really think
this needs to be
raised up the agenda as a
high priority issue
okay stacy would you like to come in
there as head of legal
yeah i would thank you chair um i'm also
safeguarding lead
um following the restructure and i sorry
i wasn't aware that this was an
action on the um audit and governance
committee but um
it is in hand um we have had an internal
safeguarding review i think that was 12
to 18 months ago
um with some recommendations um we've
got
a newly formed i say newly formed and
we've got an internal safeguarding team
and then i also attend the um
external safeguarding meetings with the
other devon authorities as well
um so it is in hand i think we do fraud
it shortly so hopefully that will give
the audit and governance committee
some assurance as as to the protocols
and procedures that we
have got in place and we have got an
internal um safeguarding policy
i think there was some discussion
originally there was going to be a
joined up one amongst the other
authorities that that's not come to
fruition
and we've got our own safeguarding
policy
um within torridge which is is not
dissimilar to other authorities but
there isn't actually one singular one
amongst everyone so happy to um
forward that information for the next
audit and governance committee um if
that helps sharon if that helps
counselor hodgson are you happy with
that claire
sorry i am very confident that our
safeguarding policy is in place
um and that it is you know stacy's taken
control of that and i have no
concerns regarding that what i do have
concerns about
is the exchange of information between
authorities
and an information sharing protocol
because we have places that are
sort of borderline with another
authority that children may go to school
in another authorities area and we need
to be able to share that information
and this was the the query was never
aimed at our own safeguarding policies
it was about the county-wide
district information sharing protocol
which there seemed to be some issues
with actually
adopting a protocol to be allowed to
share information
so that's what i would like stacey and
request stacey
in her new role to follow up on and to
get back to us
pdq stacy if you'd like to come back on
that
please yeah sorry council hudson again i
i've probably spoken at course purposes
um
there should never be an issue with
sharing information when it comes to
safeguarding of any individuals
um so i'm a little surprised that there
needs to be a formal protocol in place
because
i i think people get quite hung up on
data protection and not sharing
information
um and and that is seen as a bar but
certainly
i'm obviously part of my role as data
protection officer as well
but when it comes to welfare issues
there certainly shouldn't be a bar on
sharing information
um we do within torridge and we report
it to devon county council we also
um fairly regularly make rap mash
referrals as well
um and helen page and jan have
a regular multi-agency meetings really
for that purpose
to to make sure that people don't fall
off the radar and and items
are reported um i'll have a look see
there's our formal sharing protocol but
i
um we've got a internal one to show
when we will make these referrals and
certainly the team are very aware
um that you know if it's uh we've got
fears for somebody's safety or
well-being that those those reports must
be made
and logged on our system so i'll see if
there's a
formal protocol but i i wouldn't want
our officers to not act um
waiting for that protocol if that makes
sense because
it's too important as you rightly say
right thank you stacy thank you chair
for letting me
say my piece i still think that and i
will actually continue this conversation
with
stacy outside this meeting because this
arose
from an observation about county-wide
protocols so
i think we need to have some clarity on
it so we can come back
and complete this action thank you okay
thank you thank you claire right moving
on to item four which is the declaration
of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is being
discussed
item 5 agreement of agenda items part 1
and part two
we do have a part two item this
afternoon
so i'm going to propose from the chair
that we take a recorded vote
to agree that we do have a part two item
so
i'm looking for a seconder
i'll second that thank you claire
right would you like to take the vote
please kirsty
thank you chair councillor craigie or
councillor hackett for councillor heppel
four councillor hudson
thank you unanimous chair
thank you kirsty item six urgent matters
of information to be brought forward
with the permission of the chair
i do not have any so we will move on to
item number seven which is the code of
governance
and we are to receive a report from the
service improvement officer
so i shall pass you over to chris
thank you chair um
each year we publish a code of
governance
and this sets out um what the council
intends to do
in meeting the seven principles of good
governance
um then later in the year we produced
the ags
which actually um comments on our
achievement of those
uh principles basically this document is
the same as last year
except if you turn to page 28
page 28 is a schematic that sets out our
kind of governance framework
um and i've adjusted it this year to
affect the changes from the um
summer's restructure so just kind of
briefly
we now have a ceo who's in responsible
corporate management the section 151
officer
is now special for um risk management
arrangements
and also the um the audit partnership
who supports reports directly to the
section 151 officer
legal services now look after the um agf
the strategy and performance and i.t
team are looking after the business
plans
and customer complaints and hr
and are looking out for the um old
communications
so it's just kind of a summary page
summarizing our governance framework
how it all fits together but if
anybody's got any comments on this
document
i'm happy to discuss it
thank you very much chris um ruth craig
you would like to have um a comment
server to you
thanks um i'd just like us to beef up a
bit if we
possibly could the environmental
benefits and the sustainability
part of it it's not um
well it doesn't really mention it a
great deal at all
and when it does say sustainable i think
it means on the sustainably economic
basis rather than
you know climate change basis
could could i suggest that the climate
change committee
um is allowed to discuss you know it's
referred to them that they can sort of
uh be fit up a little bit
um this kind of document is is
it's a summary of what cyprus sets out
for councils to do
um so it's kind of a tick sheet against
which all councils are judged
um so in terms of the document of the
actual what we're going to do
it's kind of fairly generic what we can
do is in our
evidence database have additional
information if members require that
uh that would be a better way of doing
it maybe
um we can say yeah we're doing this as
well in our evidence database
we've got all this kind of doing is
saying yeah we're gonna meet um
requirements and then i'm happy to
change it it's just that it sets out
a standard kind of genetic all council
approach what's expected to happen
okay council hudson claire he would like
to come in
at this point yes please
um when i was looking at this i note
that
obviously in your sort of diagrams on
page 27 and 28
it means mentions and draws attention to
our committee structure in between
our committee structure we have
recognized the
importance of the role of lead members
for specific services
and looking at how that service is
delivered and relaying
that to the rest of the council
in fact endorsing reports etc
and i don't see where
this is noted within these schematics
because they are an important part
of the checks and balances on how
we function and i wondered
if i know it makes it a little more
complicated in the pictures but
i think there is a role and if we are
going to recognize
and reinforce the role of lead members
for
these certain service areas we need to
recognize that in our governance
structure
i think that's a really good point
claire i'll actually put a box in there
it's just something that should be in
there you're right
thank you
okay are there any more comments by
any member
right in the absence of any more
comments
um
are we happy or i am happy to propose
from the chair that we accept this
report subject to the modifications that
chris
is going to draw up and incorporate
so i'm looking for a seconder
i think council hudson clay you got in
there first
are you happy to second yes i'm happy to
second
right thank you
right over to you kirsty for the
recorded vote
thank you chair councillor craigie
well i'll vote for it but i'm going to
try and get it changed a bit
more in the sustainable development
you know kind of an area but i i
i mean i like it as it goes so i vote
for it
okay thank you councillor hackett
thank you that's unanimous chair
thank you thank you very much kirsty
right
if we move on to item eight which is the
ags
review of evidence and again to receive
a report from the service improvement
officer so
back to you again chris
thank you chair and this is a supporting
database
to evidence that um what we are doing
when it sets out in the code we actually
are doing it
um for this meeting the chairs ask that
we review two areas
um principle c2 is providing sustainable
economic
social environmental benefits and
principle g1
is about implementing good practice in
transparency
if you tend to page 31.
so the first of these uh c2
if you look the middle column actually
describes what ship to think we should
have in place
and then on the right we have what what
toy district council actually have in
place
um so we talked to this first one it's
firstly saying we should have a capital
investment
uh structure and we have our medium town
financial strategy
should have a capital program um it's
just giving examples there that we have
um our budgetary system a capital
program
and also there's comments from both cnr
and internal
overview and scrutiny and then the
forecast is minuted
and so we should have a capital
investment strategy and again
we have a strategy there in place
um next was just saying about discussion
between members of officers
um the example there just in a report
showing that the lead member
this case the chair provides a comment
on a
committee report next one is about
recording of decision making and
supporting materials
um all of our committee reports should
look at risk management
legal and financial implications um i
picked an example of the
future high street fund last july and
this kind of gives you full details on
these measures
and helped councils reach a decision and
it kind of looked at full
financial matters
um next one was recording decision
making and supporting materials
um and again that's really back to the
previous one about the house street fund
as an example um post course for
consultation
is set up in the constitution we also
have a communication strategy
and a consultation strategy and then the
last one is about
um insurance or access um
we have equation diversity policy we
also our website
meets with accessibility criteria so
in terms of this kind of principle scene
two i completely i think we actually
meet the criteria that's it sets
i'll have to take any questions on that
one
right does any member have any questions
counselor craigie ruth over to you
thanks
i'm sorry to bang on about the climate
change committee i don't know
but i think it needs to be in this i
mean it's a sleeve member as a
consultant but
really think the climate change
committee needs to be consulted on a lot
of things
and i'm afraid that they're being
sidelined a little bit at the moment
i'll raise this at the committee
that i mean big capital decisions um
you know we're doing a procurement plan
and
i think everything has to be referred to
the climate change committee
basically else we're not adhering to the
fact that we've declared a climate
change emergency
yeah i'll actually have something in
there uh councillor craig about that
i think all the british reports actually
have climate change criteria anyway
and i know that janet has actually put
together a list to make sure that all
business plans
and all areas take it take her climate
change into place
uh for all kind of actions and things so
after that
where is it in here well
it needs to go in 2.2 my decision making
i need to have something in there in 2.2
um about decision making and providing
information to members to make decisions
i need to speak that up to include yeah
if it could say
the time of change could be committee
could be um
consulted on all major financial
decisions because
um as i say we've agreed to the
climate change emergency we've set up a
committee but now we're just carrying on
as
before i mean i have said before about
having a
plan you know a carbon audit and people
think that
in on this committee we just deal with
money but
we hold it in governance and governance
is
how we treat the environment as well as
how we treat all the other things and i
think it's really important
that we we've got it in all our
documents that we're going to refer
that everything we do we will be looking
at the environmental impacts
and the carbon impacts the climate
change impacts
and then we may have to choose that we
can't afford to do the right thing we
have to do another thing
that is fair enough but we have to be
able to have the facts before we can
choose
yeah yeah and going forward all only
business plans
will be taking an impact on climate
change measures anyway so
you'll see feeding forward business and
actions will have climate change in
there
and it will be reported through the qbr
system um
to uh overview and scrutiny so yeah
that's happening
uh more than you think i think so it
might seem like nitpicking to you but
i mean cnr is looking at waste um
you know the plan for waste and
recycling
and it should have gone to the climate
change committee for their
recommendations first before it went to
cnr
not just we found out about it but you
know
through the grapevine that they were
discussed in the waste management
program
therefore that's that's why i want it
written in to the procedures
i'm trying not to be you know nitpicking
and
and petty but unless we do this unless
it's written in the procedures it won't
happen
can i just bring in david hayes our 151
officer
at the moment i know he'd like to speak
on this point
yeah so over to david yeah thank you
thank you i mean um
perhaps stacy can come in obviously
we've only just recently adopted the
council's constitution
and we do have committees that have um
responsibility for making decisions
i think it may be um
challenging in the committee cycle for
have to make a statement that every
decision needs to go through the climate
change committee
would add uh some burden to the
decision-making process that we have
you know we have a constitution which
says what um
community and resources can agree we
have a constitution says what full
council can do
i'm not sure what our constitution
actually says about every decision
because i mean that's too
that's quite a bland a wide-ranging
statement to say that everything should
go through
the climate claims committer it to me it
feels like is it not the focus be that
the climate change committee should be
making proposals to
cnr or full council for their approval
so for example when we
had that discussion about sustainable
investment councillor craig
that went through the climate change
committee and then has filtered up
through
internal overview and scrutiny and on
the 22nd of february
full council will be presented with a
revised treasury management policy
saying within parameters the council
should prioritize making
um its short-term treasury deposits and
sustainable um
investments so have we got this i'm just
wondering if we've got this the right
way around is it that you know should it
not be that the
climate change committee is making
suggestions for the decision-making
bodies of the council
i'm happy to first if stacy wants to
correct me on any mistakes i've made in
the council's constitution
do you want me to come in and stacy yes
i'm happy to come in
yeah uh just just to reiterate uh what
what david said
um in reality so we we have just i mean
i think the constitution working
sorry the climate change working group
has probably been ongoing
for some time um in an informal basis
but council craigie we recognize the
importance of the climate change working
group
which is why when we took the um
amendments to the constitution to full
council
um we we asked for the climate change
working group to be formally recognized
within the constitution
um in terms of the constitution itself
we don't generally have working groups
mentioned in the constitution because
as david's quite rightly said they're
not decision-making bodies
um but to recognize the importance and
the fact that torridge had declared a
climate emergency that's why we felt
that it was important
for it to have that formal recognition
um but the group are making
recommendations and those
recommendations are to go to cnr
um as david quite rightly said it it
would be hard to put everything through
the climate change working group
um you know and in some respects i mean
i
i know that you were talking about the
treasury management policy before and
there are other different legal
ramifications as to why we can and can't
do stuff but
certainly jan is working with the other
managers now you've adopted the policy
and that is in our strategic plan and
we'll field
filter through all our business plans so
please make sure
you're not being sidelined um we do
recognize it as an importance and we're
going to try and get some formality to
the group
going forward and things will start
filtering
filtering through to you shortly um you
know the waste strategy was a very
separate one
and but you know we've had discussions
regarding the environmental center
um that hasn't skipped the climate
change working group
and the reason that has been presented
thus far is for
the budget to be agreed for it so until
we get the budget agreed we
we can't do anything um further so um
but i'm sure it's something that that
the group will be consulted on
um going forward if that helps
yeah thank you very much okay
right um chris over back to you
yeah if we move on to page 33 um
onto transparency which is um
g1 i'm just looking through here in the
middle column
um information the website we actually
have all
agendas and minutes on our website we
also have information guys and datasets
on the website
it mentions public participation um
we have competition in key meetings in
fact i think with the zoom
there's actually more public
participation there used to be um
i'll put an example in their public
contributions to full council
uh moving forward um constitution is on
is on the website video information is
all on the website the information
and we produce an annual report we also
publish all explainations over 500
pounds on the website
a london property list um the last one
we published there was april 2019
and uh list of all council grants again
the last one we published there was 2019
april
uh fees and charges are up to date on
the website and
office delegated decisions are listed on
the website
and then the planning portal includes
all the planning decisions
i'd mark this one taken sync compliance
because we had a couple of items there
which
uh slightly out of date in terms of
property and grants
um that was due mainly to officers being
involved with
curbid commitments um we are due soon to
publish
2021 years as well so um
on a transparent was slightly late on
two items there
it's just a question really of whether
we accept that due to kerbin that's the
kind of consequence or whether
we actually ask that those items are
updated on the website
but any other comments please right
cancer hudson claire you would like to
just come in on
that point wouldn't you yes i just
actually
have raised this and again it is about
the capacity of officers who have been
working so hard during covid and this is
not
in any way a criticism so please don't
take it that way
you've acknowledged that two things are
out of date
the constitution on page 34
at the head of that says constitution
2018
this has been superseded by an approved
constitution
that we approved back in november um
and it needs it it needs to be uploaded
so the constitution would be 2020
not 2018. so uh i think we need to note
that
and um i have raised it
with the chief exec
and it is a simple not a simple matter
because nothing ever is simple but it is
a question of putting
what full council has agreed on the
website
thank you okay thank you
just as a matter of interest we have got
our
youtube library of committee meetings
have we any thought as to how long they
will be up
and live for are they going to be in
perpetuity or they
time limited has any thought being given
on that
probably a question for stacey i think
so we're talking about future committee
meetings
well the current ones how long do we
archive them for do we have a policy on
it or are we going to
see how things go i don't think we've
got a policy
on um dates of meetings we've got a
policy on retention of minutes of of
meetings
i'm talking about the retention of the
the meetings that are currently
accessible on youtube
are they going to be up there for a time
limited period or they there for
the end of time sort of thing yeah i
don't know actually that's a very good
question council hacking
she's just so bored you know everyone
who's
who knows me is laughing because
technology isn't my thing and it
probably be a question
i assume they stay there but but perhaps
tom could
confirm yeah they do stay up there for
as long as we want
we can remove them if we want to remove
them after six months but currently
since we've been doing this in march
they are all still on the youtube
channel
but it's something okay i love you yeah
that's fine
it's fine okay not a problem right um
you don't wish to come back on anything
do you chris
no that was just a noting chair thank
you okay that's right so the
recommendation is that
the evidence contained in sections c2
and
section g1 of the supporting database is
duly noted so um
we're happy to do that and move on to
item nine which is managing the risk
of fraud and corruption self-assessment
and to receive
the report from rob hutchins of the
devon audit partnership
um gaston chair good afternoon members
and before we start would it be possible
for me to introduce my colleague paul
middlemas
who's on the call with us today um it's
good afternoon paul
good afternoon hi paul is a relatively
new audit manager to develop a
partnership and he's helping us with our
work at
mid devon and north devon currently um
our hope is or our expectation is that
once paul's got his
feet under the table and learned um our
row with
with our district house and colleagues
that he will then become
uh the lead manager for your work at
torridge
so um yeah so i want to um uh yeah just
introduce
paul to you today um and paul may stay
for the meeting and see what's happening
um but uh um yeah i just wanted to
introduce him to you
um yes nice and nine in your uh gender
pack is um
managing risk of fraud corruption
self-assessment so something i bring to
the committee
every year um it's our assessment of the
arrangements in place to
try to prevent detect and then
investigate fraud and corruption
it is more of an update really um to the
committee
um not to lose sight of the importance
of this
on page 37 it's just some a table of
stats there
um the data is a little bit owed back in
2013 the last time this was provided
nationally but you see some some of the
very big numbers that are involved
in what's estimated to be the value of
fraud
so a very clear need for us to ensure
we've got robust
procedures in place clearly at that
table doesn't mean that uh
that those frauds are occurring at uh at
torridge
but as areas that we need to make sure
that we've got robust arrangements in
place to prevent
so we've completed a self-assessment
with the help of officers
and and that starts on page
41 of your of your packs
so this is a self-assessment that cipher
recommend
it's been it's completed um it's quite
comprehensive
um there's quite a lot of detail there
and i think that's quite uh right and
helpful uh clearly there's other things
that the organization does to
prevent and detect fraud as well as but
this is just our summary against those
key things that's it for identified
um as i say you have seen it before um
so i just really want to bring out to
you or point out to you some of the
changes the new ones
so at the bottom of page 41 um hopefully
you can see it says
new uh that there should be a relevant
portfolio holder
um and to be uh to be briefed and be
aware of fraud risk and mitigation in a
broader sense and we can send it off
that road
falls to the chair of the audit and
governance committee so
we'll be expecting to brief your chair
um
in respect of that and number five is
the audit committee is supporting
counter fraud
uh work and challenging level of
activity to make sure it's appropriate
i think that's really where we're
looking for this committee uh to take on
that road to support officers in their
work
as i say to prevent detect and
investigate forward and corruption
um not always the easiest thing to do um
and it's also it's not the easiest and
not the nicest thing to do at times
either
and that's why you've got officers from
uh from double order partnership
and we can help provide those kind of
specialist skills
if uh and when the time is required
um so the rest support really is is an
update
on areas of good practice that have
already been in place um
at torridge and hopefully that gives the
committee some comfort some assurance
that arrangements are
uh strong robust and reliable um so way
of introduction that's probably all that
brings the attention to committee but
very happy to take any any questions or
expand
further thank you rob
um and welcome paul
um councillor craigie ruth you'd like to
come in on a point
thank you chair i don't know whether
it's at the pro this is appropriate
point or the on the next
um matter on the agenda but
um i was wondering if um rob could tell
us
what if there's been any noticeable
problems with the kovid grants
that they were rolled out at such speed
um
i would have thought that was one
potential you know
risk of fraud and i just wondered if
we've got a sort of initial guide of
um overall whether it's gone well or
whether there's been significant
you know people misclaiming um yes
thank you for the question you're
absolutely right there is a there has
been
an increased risk of fraud and
corruption due to covid
um there i should rightly say a lots of
um grants have been paid out
uh by the local authorities um up and
down the country
and when um the admission instructions
that came through to
local authorities was to make those
payments quickly
and that the main instruction was what
get the money out really quickly
and um paul might comment on this
because
from another side of the of the uh
government
machinery and paul was involved in this
from from beis
side of things but um
there was a report later on in your
packs which does cover uh the payment of
grant claims
and we give them reasonable assurance
are the arrangements in place by
torridge
um and we think there have been uh
robust and reasonable checks
undertaken um and that's that's both
before making the payments and then uh
pre after after
so both pre and posts are making their
payments so there's checks being
undertaken and
both before the favorites and after the
payments being made
to make sure that cover grants being
paid
accurately to the right people and to
minimize that risk of fraud
so you're right there definitely has
been an increased risk because of the
speed of payments being made out to
people
and the fact that it was a new payment
system but our report later in the packs
in new pac does pick up on that and
gives a level of resource assurance
thank you paul i don't know if you want
to to raise anything from
from your side of things when you're in
your previous room
no i just think you're you're right in
terms of providing that the summary of
the government knew there was a
massive sort of massive increased risk
of fraud
in the environment but the whole
emphasis was on making
you know issuing grants at speed um
but but um
um accompanied by a sort of um priority
to
do some more post payment checks so
whereas grants continue to be made but
as i said the the government is sort of
asking councils to do more post payment
checks but i think
at the moment councils are pushing back
to some extent because they don't have a
capacity to do
a huge amount of work in this area but
um
i think the the the the checking that
we've done
um in the devon area seems to indicate
that i think the council probably have
got a good
um picture of the local environment and
the businesses who are
claiming uh grants and so on which
probably reduces
the risk in this area anyway that's
that's my sort of impression
okay can i just bring david hayes in
here um david you've raised your hand do
you want to come in on this point
uh yes chair thank you very much um
i think as rob's alluded to at the start
of the process there was a
a great deal of pressure to get money
out the door quickly
which obviously if you want to process
payments quickly there's elements of
potential fraud um just
however within torridge about the start
of the process i think the potential for
that was
relatively limited because we
proactively mail shotted
those businesses that we felt were
actually liable for the grant
okay however of course then other
businesses came out and said oh no we
think
we're liable because we're actually a
holiday home or we're actually a shop
rather than a warehouse
but they then had to go through a
process with the valuation office to
change their status on the rating system
in order to be
eligible alongside that initial tranche
of grants
was uh some discretionary grants for
businesses that weren't
subject to business rates or
bed and breakfast accommodation market
traders for businesses for whatever
reason
weren't on the business rate system but
were essentially affected by the first
national lot down
and the evaluation of those um grants
was done by our colleagues at north
devon plus and they
people who applied for those grants went
for a very very rigorous
application process so that didn't give
me any sleepless
nights at all of any potential of
fraudulent applications given the
steps that the applicants would have to
go through
however since then there's been
progressively more and more streams of
grants come along and
i've got to admit that the council has
struggled to do the post verification
check work that we should do
now we've actually now gone to some
extent got on top of that
and i just want to explain to members
what that actually entails well it's
actually entailed
one particular office of mine working
overtime i've been perfectly honest
we submit all the grants that we've paid
through the nfi
portal national fraud initiative portal
and that checks for companies whether
companies only just recently been set up
dissolved um checks the bank accounts
and so what then comes out we're coming
out with a hit list of um
information that's combat from the nfl
that says these are the high-risk ones
so what we've then done is we actually
check the bank accounts
and check that the bank account agrees
with the name of the company that we
believe we should be paying
and then we've also done officers in my
team have been checking
um websites and social media to check
that the business was actually
functioning
and that's what they've been doing now
so we've now checked the first transfer
which is over 2800
grants that we've paid gone through that
process and we've narrowed it down
and we're probably in the region now of
60 where we need to do detailed checking
to reassure
ourselves that the grants that we paid
were correct
and that doesn't mean they're they're
not correct it's just that we've got to
a point where
we can't see say a holiday let we can't
actually from the information available
to us we can't see that that actually
was actively marketed
as a holiday accommodation doesn't mean
it just means we don't have enough
information to find that info
so but there i will say this is a
tremendous
burden on the council at the moment
which is consuming a heck of a lot
of officer time and with very successive
waiver grants
we're going to have to do the same
process again and i think today
we're doing another submission to the
national fraud initiative
so i can't handle heart say to members
that we haven't paid grants out
maybe to the wrong people i'd like to
say that we've minimized it with a
combination of local knowledge the
proactive
asking of people to apply that we
believe are eligible the discretionary
side which has been done by our north
devon plus colleagues
but the scale of what we've paid out
this year
has been somewhat of a challenge for the
council
okay thank you david um i've got three
hands up
council hudson councillor heppell and
caster craigie so i'll go to
um euclaire first
thank you david for adding i think
you've almost
answered one of the questions i was
raising with regard to there was
some concern and dismay across the
entire county if not every area that has
holiday lets that these grants were
being paid
out to holiday lets
or stroke second homes
and i did i was writing down what i was
going to ask
and i heard you saying something about
second homes
and holiday lets and the ability to
actually
check and validate that they are
marketing themselves
as a holiday business to qualify for the
grant so if in a minute you could come
back to me on that
the second one is quite an easy one you
actually state on page 41
about new number four the relevant
portfolio holder
has been briefed on the fraud risks and
mitigation
now and you note that as being the chair
of uh
of gov the government audit and
governance committee more than happy
however i am lead member for finance and
audit
and vice chair of this committee so can
i please be briefed as well
thank you okay
right i'll move on to councillor hepple
so over to you
kit um thank you
does david want to come back on claire's
first question there
yes please uh so counselors are just
unclear when we're talking about the
holiday lets
so you got to remember some of the
information we've got so say it's called
five the high street and it's in our
business rate system as a holiday let
okay so at the start of the process they
were on the business rate system
as a holiday let and in that first grant
that we paid we proactively
wrote to people who come to the
government guidance were eligible for
grant so in this case it would be
classed as a holiday let on business
rates
we would have solicited a application
from them
and then applied what we've then
subsequently done on the post grant
the post grant payment verification work
is see if we can see that that property
is
actively being let well that's not that
sometimes it's easy
where it's honeysuckle cottage you type
under honeysuckle
cottage and you can probably find that
on
bookings.com that's available for let
some of these ones we've struggled to
find that they are available to let and
that is the
subset of the ones that we need to um
carry out further investigation working
essentially ask them to prove
that they have actually marketed that
accommodation
as a holiday let so what we've done is
on the ones which we believe are high
risk from the first
tranche of grants we're not going to
make any further grant payments as in
the second national lockdown the
latino lockdown that we're in now so
that's the process we're doing
what i just what i'm trying to say is as
well is i have limited officer resource
to that so the person who's actually
doing that work
in terms of um trying to establish if
she can see that property is being
actively marketed
she's doing that on the day that she
doesn't work
right did that answer your question
sorry council hud's another missed the
point
do you wish to come back on that claire
i'm trying to but i every time i unmute
myself somebody mutes me again um
yeah thank you in part um
not you in part or the officer doing the
work
it is not a of an exact science and i do
understand that
and they're always going to be loopholes
but there have been great concerns that
people
might even advertise their properties
but put such exorbitant
costs for renting their premises that
they actually
exclude themselves from being a rental
business
i j you know income tax returns etc
when you run a business um would be
but i'm not expecting you or have an
expectation
for you to go that far because of um
the capacity of your team so but we need
to acknowledge it
as potentially there are people out
there who have benefited from this
yeah so as well council has just just as
a general observation of course
if i was um living in i don't know
say i normally resident in manchester
and had a second home
down in north devon if i was to put it
up and say
if you know lie essentially and say it
was a holiday home
i wouldn't have to pay council tax so i
said because it'd be registered for
small business rates
and i wouldn't pay any business rates so
there may be people who were
on business rates and that's not
actually valid because it wasn't
actually a functioning business
the that's the difficulty we've got and
the difficulties we have in torridge is
the sheer volume of them
because we had a a holiday destination
so we acknowledge that um you know
putting what resource i can in my team
but it's difficult
whilst at the same time processing all
the other discretionary grants that are
coming through
and all the other government
thank you very much i do understand and
appreciate your difficulties
thank you okay steve hurts would you
like to come on in this i see you've uh
put your hand up uh thanks james it was
only only just briefly
um obviously the the issue around second
home second home
owners has been raised nationally and
certainly the chair of what's called the
devon districts forum
um which was councillor judy pierce the
leader of south hams
had written directly to the secretary of
state regarding some of these issues
around second home home homes and second
home owners
uh being eligible for such grants
so you know it has been picked up we've
i said we've reported it nationally
um and i'll circulate a copy of the the
letter that's come back from
the secretary of state for the
department of uh business energy and
industrial strategy so
i'll circulate that letter to members of
the committee so you can see um
have assurance that it has been picked
up and being dealt with
thank you steve right um
if you don't wish to come back claire i
sure move on to kit apple's point
okay um just very briefly following on
from uh
councillor hudson's uh point there on
second homes i'd like to endorse
like everybody would the concerns uh
that everybody i speak to has on the
issue and i just wondered if
when things get back to normal which i'm
sure they will eventually and we do have
more
resources available is is the idea of
post investigation on
grants that have been paid out time
limited or can
is it is it going to be something that
can be looked at in more detail
when the time is available that's my
first point
and second point was if i could just
refer rob to
page 45 item 24 and
um there being no response plan as such
in position it's really just the um
i suppose it hinges on availability
of resources but i'm i'm concerned that
torridge district council at the moment
don't have
the manpower to actually
go through with all of that in terms of
prevention detain
detection investigation in particular
investigation
because um there's an issue i
that was raised in one of my parish
council meetings where i
raised the issue initially with um
planning
control back on the 25th of november i
think and
i chased it yesterday just to see how
if there'd been any progress in order to
report back to the committee meeting
last night
and they hadn't even opened a file on it
um i i you know i i know that
the enforcement officers he said to me
he's got 200 cases
that he's dealing with um it just seems
that we
we we can't have a response plan that's
implemented
capable of being implemented if we
haven't got the resources
that's my point really okay
does an officer wish to respond to that
i could i could start a response and i
suppose that dave might want to come in
as well that's okay
um for my view i don't think there's any
time not as such
um for investigating um the grant claims
i don't think it's time limited in that
respect it will be resource limited
uh i think one of the things you're
going to have is that the question
around
diminishing returns in some respects um
so you know it's
the value i suppose of what the
potential issue is
versus the time required to investigate
that and that's that's a tricky one
because we always try to say to this
committee
you know zero tolerance to uh fraud
um it's difficult to set that zero
tolerance because everybody knows that
it costs
money in terms of time to undertake an
investigation
and i think as well come back on that
point number 24
uh no response plan as such i think
it is a bit of an issue um it comes down
to resources as
david was referring to really in that um
the level
of fraud and corruption in the in torres
has traditionally been
low um and so there isn't a uh dedicated
officer if you will
um picking that up um i think what we're
saying is that there's the resources
potentially available for example it
could be
by contracting more personnel today for
the development partnership or elsewhere
um but so there are the resources aren't
necessarily there in terms of a
dedicated resource
um but it's the ability to draw in and
bring in
expert assistance as the need may
require um so that would be my response
to
those two points if that helps
okay stacy i'll bring you in and then
come to steve
yeah thank you chair um i know there's
there's a lot of talk on um you know the
government grants being paid out very
quickly and the checks that have been
put in place and i i think
um both myself and david were very
concerned as to the the level
of um the speed that these grants were
paid out and i think in in
in an ideal world we would have wanted
far more time to put
but what we would see as as more
appropriate measures in place
but that being said and and i
i think gary audited our grant and did
the post payment um checks uh
on top of the post payment checks that
torridge had done actually
i think in the whole of the um grants
that have been paid out
there's one that's been paid by mistake
um
and and that money was was recruited was
recouped so i i i think there is a lot
of highlight on
on potential fraud i think we haven't
actually
even um in hindsight actually seen
any kind of pacific cases and i think
the other thing to bear in mind is um
we've had a lot of um uh talk about
a lack of resources um but
um going forward
it's if there was a difficulty
we certainly would take that up but i i
there hasn't been a clear plan from the
government as to whether they would be
doing the investigations or whether
torridge would be doing the
investigations
i think at the moment and we've just
been simply asked to inform the
government
and i think from david and i's
perspective our we were quite strong on
the checks
and because our concern at that stage
was that this money could recruit being
recruited directly back from torridge
um and when you're paying out millions
and millions of pounds in grants
if we'd have got it wrong that could
have put us in severe difficulty
um so i think council headphones will in
in relation to the other enforcement
case that's planning enforcement so it
is
is quite separate to this grant payment
a separate team separate departments
okay steve over to you uh
thanks chair um i think uh david and
stacey covered quite a lot
of it anyway um but i think just to
recap in terms of the
the grants issue obviously as they both
indicated there's a huge amount of
pressure
at the start to get the grants out the
door and you know that
that pressure was being pushed from the
very
top you know authorities that weren't
uh performing very well in the league
tables that
were publicized at the time the chief
execs of those authorities were getting
individual calls from junior
ministers challenging and questioning
why that wasn't happening and that's
certainly something that didn't happen
for us
and you know i'm proud and happy to say
that that you know the team
worked remarkably well to get get all of
those grants out and as states he said
you know having one page incorrectly it
is a real significant uh achievement
in terms of the the wider resource issue
obviously members will be aware from the
conversations we've been having around
the the budget
through the the the workshop we held
recently
through the ongoing discussions we've
had about a budget there is a finite
amount of resources
and if you put additional resource in
one area
the way the ballot the budget is uh
poised you have to take something out
of another area you can't do everything
and keep
putting more resource to everything
without there being
an impact somewhere else so if you want
you know if you do put
more into planning enforcement then
something else has to suffer so it's
a careful and tricky balance now
since we've implemented or i've
implemented the new
management structure each of the
individual
operational managers have been looking
at their individual
services the structure of the services
and the resources
they need to deliver uh what members
have asked
um smt management team have looked at
those
and subject to the budget being approved
at the end of february uh
any of those changes will be implemented
but again as i said we are working with
it in a
within a finite set of budget
availability if we had a
bottomless pit for the one to the better
word then everything would be
gold-plated we would have officers
available to do all sorts of different
things but unfortunately in the current
climate that just
isn't possible so we have to prioritize
and move things around
to deliver something of everything
rather than
absolutely everything thanks sure
right thank you very much i think it's
it's all due credit to steve david and
the team
for how they've managed to roll out
these payments
in a very time limited
chain of events because they have been
desperately needed by our communities
and you have really done a fantastic job
neat
recognition for it ruth i'll move on to
your point now that you wish to make
thank you very much chair i'm afraid i'm
accumulating points here
first the question to steve um
are we getting back from the government
not just the grants that we give out
but some money for the you know the
administration that's been involved in
giving all these grants that was the
first
question the second is related to it
david mentioned
that we're using north devon plus to do
the discretionary
grants i'm wondering what what
qualifications they've got to do that
how much they're charging and whether
we're checking on their work
so are we auditing them in turn and um
i've had a case of somebody who thinks
they should have got a grant
and they didn't because they've got a
shop but they're actually an architect
rather than
selling things per se i was wondering if
there's any appeal procedures if you
don't get a grant
okay david do you sorry sorry to have so
many questions
i i didn't mean to cut you off ruth and
david do you like to come back on this
so just remember just remind me council
craig you want your first question
what's going on i do know the answer to
all three questions
the government paying is back yes yes
they're paid as uh what's called new
burdens grant
so in addition to the actual money for
the actual administering the grants
we're also getting new burdens grant so
that we work we are being paid for that
yes
will that cover all this broad work and
checks that we're doing
yes the issue we have is not the money
that we receive but finding the resource
and expertise to actually do that
so they've got to give us students
we're using them can we not use some
account in the town uh no uh what i
would say about nafta plus just to be
aware their background is actually in
assessing businesses
you know sort of business plans that
prospective businesses put together
and want to expand and they're used to
um analyzing information when people
submit
applications for grant funding so
actually their level of expertise is
is exceptionally high in this area so
i i actually feel that if we hadn't used
north devon plus for the discretion-free
the council
would have struggled mightily to have
actually got through the volume of work
that they have done
they have actually been um we've been
fortunate to have them on board if i'm
being personally honest councillor craig
what was the third question was about a
well well the question was how much
that has it cost but i mean if that can
be just directly
charged to the government that's fair
enough i don't care what it costs if
they're paid
charged to the government it's funded by
the government so let's say are we
auditing
my other question was are we auditing
what they do
and are there any appeals procedure if
people feel that they've
not been awarded about when they should
have done right we are
auditing the um work that nafta
knockdown plus done the audit that gary
sprackley took out
involved the discretionary work so he's
actually looked at that also separately
when the information com
on the discretionary grants that north
evan plus administer they're actually
paid through the creditor payment
section in my team
and we're actually doing some checks of
the information that comes through for
checking that there's a
the bank accounts are consistent for
example that's one of the main checks
that we do
we also have checked that when i look at
something
are they covering the period they're not
duplicating periods so yes there
are checking the actual on any of the
business grants that we're
administrating at the moment there is
actually no right of appeal
that's in the government legislation
there's no right of appeal if somebody
was unhappy with a decision that
let me just tell a colleague that i'm in
a meeting please just bear with me
okay richard i'll bring you back okay
uh apologies the disadvantages are
working in the office um
there is no right of appeal and that's
in the legislation
if an officer such as karina
or made a decision not to award a grant
then she would refer that to myself or
stacy for a second opinion
but there is no formal right of appeal
so i mean to come back on that what
should i do then if i've got somebody
who's complained about not getting a
grant when they feel that they should
and they desperately need it
should i come to you well they they can
make
representations but what i'm saying is
there is no formal appeal process
that's that makes life difficult though
doesn't it
thanks thanks that's very comprehensive
and i appreciate
the detail okay
right are there any further
comments on that
rob are you have you completed your
um yes i have them thank you for the
comments there and we're certainly
making that change as well
to the um whereas capturing the
portfolio lead or make sure that change
it takes place okay thank you very much
so i believe we just um
we're asked to note that the internal
audit reviews continue to ensure that
procedures remain effective
and our date is required to counter new
and emerging fraud threats
so uh i think we duly note that
and therefore move on to item 10 which
is the audit reports issued to date
and to receive the report from the you
again rob
from from dap page 48-65
yes uh thank you again chair so yes um
normal uh a gender item for this
committee where we summarize
what was completed in the last period um
and
on page 48 of your packs you can see
that uh four
uh reports have been issued council
taxing ginkgo processing procurement and
covert business grants the item just
been discussing
so just onto the next page on page 49
you've got our opinions there um
two we're given a substantial assurance
around council tax and income processing
and then reasonable assurance around
procurement and covert 19
payment assurance um i think i always
say at this time
that um your substantial insurance is a
very good rating
um what we do have and you would have
seen because we circulate the reports to
the order committee members is the
detailed report
with an action plan and the most
important thing really is that when we
do make or fight have a finding
uh and make a recommendation is that
management can respond to that
and can make the change uh to strengthen
the control arrangements
and i feel team feeds into your process
about tracking those uh
completion of the recommendations so i
think that's a very robust and
uh worthwhile process um
so substantial assurance here means it's
a good rating
two areas of reasonable assurance and
what i was going to bring to your
attention was the
covert um kind of payments
um and just flicking through your packs
that started a little bit later on
um just getting there myself on the
pages
um
that's on page 59 oh that's the
procurement starting page 59. i do
apologize 63
i think rob thank you i've got a very
small screen as you can probably guess
yeah so there's the business grants um
the post uh
payment assurance so this was talk to
pick it up on the item just really
discuss
it gives reasonable assurance there um
and
um i think we covered the the most of
the grain that we've been talking about
really
it does highlight that there was uh one
um
incorrect payments as long as we could
save unfortunate payments
and i think yeah let's put that in
context really with the payments have
been made
and i think that should give a good
comfort really to the committee that
the team at torres had good good
arrangements and procedures in place
that's probably all it brings your
attention share but very happy to
take any questions right i think we've
covered the last item very
comprehensively
i see councillor hudson i wishes to make
a point so claire if you'd like to come
in
this muting business is a lark um
page 40 no page 60
um achieving value for money um
it says the following chart is included
for information and context
showing as it does the total value of
transactions
occurring each year there is no chart
so i'm none the wiser
on my screen there was a chart center
payments being made i think that's uh
it's a printing issue is it
potentially i'm working on screen the
achievement for
um page 60 achieving value for money the
following charts include information
so um it's a chart showing the
expenditure being made by
um it's a bar chart that's come through
my website
well for some reason it's not printed
out on our documents
no it hasn't come through rob i
apologize
um i i don't think that would alter my
opinion at all but
the the issue i did want to raise is on
page sixty
two uh the third paragraph
um regarding
where formal tendering is required the
authority in most instances makes use of
a restricted
tender process limiting the number of
tenders invited to select
to a select few contractors whilst this
may be viewed as somewhat less
transparent
more open to potential fraud or
favoritism
it's also a more efficient process with
less administrative
overheads which is an important
consideration for the small procurement
team
who are working with limited resources
now whilst i understand that this
in part i think it's something we need
to discuss
is this the best way to proceed
are we excluding potentially um
capable contractors
from the process entering into the
process
or even giving them the opportunity to
prove and evidence their capabilities
by continuously selecting from a small
number of people and i just wanted
to gauge other people's opinions on this
because i i you know it has been
discussed that we have some very
capable contractors that
might be um better equipped or
more economical or whatever
so i think we need to be clear on what
we do
with this select list okay
um i'd like to welcome to the committee
council laws nick you'd like to make a
point
actually in these times there are going
to be a lot of new startups
and they're really excluded from even
knowing about
it i mean uh knowing about a particular
tender process
i can see the reasons for it
but equally preliminary documents sent
out on request
or they should be advertised
i just totally agree with council halls
and really
just thought i'd make the point thank
you
okay thank you nick
does anyone else wish to comment
right do you want me to um bring you
back in rob
um well you can't join me that knows our
finding and um
i think the last sentence there just
says on balance the use of a strict
attend tendering is considered a
reasonable approach
so um yeah that that is our finding uh
their chair
um i guess the committee's is trying to
you know what is that kind of balance
has it gone too far one way do we need
to bring it back the other one
okay um the recommendation i have before
me committee
is that the committee are asked to note
the report issued
in this reporting period and raising the
queries suggested or proposals relating
to three internal
audits in this report so it is a matter
for noting
um are we all happy to note
thank you right we'll move on to
item 11 progress with agreed actions
to receive a report from the finance
management section 151 officer
so over to you david thank you chair
um whenever we get audits they'll have
audit findings
and sometimes the audit findings will
have a requirement for management to
make some corrective action and and
that's in the manager's comment and
you'll see the audit reports and if
there was one in my area
i would it's a we should do something
and i'll say yes i agree to do that and
we give that a time frame
so if you can turn to appendix a which
is page 69 and then
really i'm looking at pages 69 70
and 71 to be honest there's a list
essentially of actions that were agreed
by the manager where we've had
extensions to
deliver those actions and i don't think
we can shy
away from it there's a lot of extensions
in the actions in the estates
department and a lot of those actions
where we've asked for extensions relate
to sort of the management of the
existing council portfolio
of properties essentially he's doing
like stock condition surveys for its
doing an asset management plan uh
reviewing leases
some of the leases etc um
and i think the council has been the
council has been aware of this for a
little while that we've had some issues
in our property team in terms of
fulfilling vacancies and retaining staff
um
so i think the from
even wrong steve the recruitment process
finishes today to recruit a new
post as a state manager and what we're
hoping to achieve by that recruitment
will be to separate
the major projects work so so that
adrian redwood
can concentrate on the major projects
works have a new post of estates manager
that actually can concentrate on the
work connected with our existing
portfolio of properties uh our estate
essentially
um and so i think we have to recognize
we've got we've had some issues here
and this is our plan to try and address
the issues
that i just need to be brought to the
committee's attention
it can't be hidden uh those extensions
have been
like a year some of those extensions
they're things that ideally we really
should have
done okay
the one that i would
um raise up with the asset management
plan because
i think that's been about three years
has it not am i writing
that yes that's correct and
that would be a fairly substantive risk
um how can we make sure this doesn't run
into a fourth
i year the the glib and easy answer is
make sure we make an appointment
when we do the interviews for the
estates management and cr and get the
right person for the job
and create that extra resource the truth
you know the simple truth at the moment
is we have too many major projects going
on
we've also hit with the cold video in
terms of like the leisure and things
like that
and there hasn't been enough focus on
the
day-to-day that needs to be done in
terms of our existing portfolio of of
properties which actually for a council
of our size is actually quite
substantive
okay um i can see steve wants to come in
on this point so i'll just throw to
steve
uh thanks shay i think like say david
covered it quite well
um you know we are recruiting we've
recognized as members recognized
there's a need to put additional
resources into our property and
procurement team
to deliver the extensive portfolio of
projects that
uh members want us to deliver and that's
why we've you know we decided to split
the team
and put in additional resources
um as you said it is a key and critical
piece of work and sean and i
actually discussed this it was last week
um
something that needs to be developed
quite quickly
um so as david mentioned you know it can
be a priority for
a new member of staff amongst many
priorities
but yes it is it is a key piece of work
that needs needs to be done
it's something that formally had a a
statutory requirement
to be produced we had to publish publish
it
and produce it within it within a
timetable um that kind of statutory
timetable uh disappeared some years ago
but that doesn't diminish the
need for us to understand the condition
and the planning of our estate
so we've got the the property major
projects group which kind of
monitors what's going on and as you know
as you'll know agent reports that group
any particular issues or concerns around
our state around our assets but you know
it does clearly need to be
consolidated so we know the condition of
it we've got
forward plans in terms of maintenance
and management
of all of our all of our assets so well
i think
all the information say it just needs a
lot of pulling together a lot of survey
work
uh and something that you know the the
new estates manager
assuming we appoint of course because we
can't uh uh
categorically confirm that there will be
somebody in post and
that individual may might have a number
of months notice on a
previous um post so you know
once we've got a date uh of december i
think we will need to review
uh the capacity within the team and you
know the
when that individual starts
okay so if we don't appoint you have a
plan b
in mind to cover that's that's good
okay um right
does any other member of the committee
wish to come in on that
nope okay
do you wish to make any further comments
david or we
nope okay so uh we are happy to
note the progress the actions in this
quarter
okay thank you so we can move on to the
next item
which is the audit plan to receive a
report from the finance management
section 151 officer again
and on page 73 over to you dave
seems somewhat grandiose to call it
report when it's actually just a
spreadsheet
but anyway we'll go with that okay
essentially myself and rob sat down to
discuss
the audit plan for the year 2021-22
and just to give members some background
um
we appear most certain audits we carry
out every year
other audits will carry out periodic and
generally you focus the attention
of an audit where things have changed or
there's been changes of staff for
example
um so this year of course one of the
fake things of course is covered
so we've had a watch chat about the plan
so we put certain things in there so we
put in like the hardship grant for track
and trace payments
that's something we've never done before
but we felt that was something that we
should audit
because it's new we've obviously put in
stuff about
ict i mean in it about home working
because you know the vast majority of
the council is that today is working
from home apart from our frontline
refuge staff so we've put
that in but obviously we had a limited
number of days available to us
in um the from the devon audit patch or
some things had to give if we were
adding new audits
some things had to give so the criteria
that myself and rob agreed was that we
would not
audit things where they've had previous
years have had good audits
where there's been no fundamental
changes to systems
and there's been no turnover staff so
generally every year we would
audit our creditor payment system and i
hope as rob would back me up
every year we get a very good score
from the audit for our credit to payment
system it's a team
that's well established there's no been
no turnover of staff
and there's been no fundamental change
in processes so we decided for one year
only
to remove the credit of payments audit
which we'd normally would do every year
and also so we generally get a very good
score on our main accounting systems
audit so we've paired that audit back
for next year so what i'm trying to say
to you is you look at the
audit plan in front of you it'll be a
combination of trying to encapsulate
some new
challenges of things where everything
changes so i think um
i put car parking in there because we've
had a turnover of staff
some long serving stuff jane rodgers
left us after many years of service
patrick who was her assistant our solar
so we've put in
and we've introduced a new spa smart
parking permit system so that's why that
one's been given some priority this year
so it's really for members to consider
just understand the process by how me
and rob
went about arriving at the audit plan
okay right thank you david
anybody wish to make any comment on that
or do we duly
note as a committee so in the absence of
any comments we will duly note and move
on to item 13
which is the ripper update to receive a
report from the finance manager again
so back to you david i'm grateful that
my colleague stacey dory has agreed to
do this one for me
right stacy it is i think that's only
fair
um as as the lead um officer for ripper
but
um the the letter page or the report at
page 74
um outlines the position um
so we were audited by the investigation
powers commissioner's office in december
in relation
to um the procedures that we have in
place for ripper
um the protocols the application forms
um he also looked at a couple of the rip
authorizations that had been made and
and by and large
um was happy um with the procedures and
policies
that we'd put in place was extremely
happy to hear that it's reported to
order in governance for it to be
reviewed
um and i think the only real
recommendation
um in relation to it was that we haven't
historically been very good
at noting the ripper authorization has
ended
um although the teams know it's ended
we've not formally recorded that on the
documents
um and i think subject to
that um investigation or sorry the
report i'm reminded officers across the
authority regarding the use of social
networking sites
um i think it can be very very tempting
um nowadays
to go and look at social media in
relation to the investigations that we
undertake as a whole um and whilst
there's an acceptance by the court that
if you
put um matters on a social networking
site that is largely public
there isn't an expectation that a public
authority is viewing it with a view to
an investigation
so staff have had that reminder um
look we we we haven't had any
unauthorized um
ripper activity i'm pleased to say um
yeah i'm happy to take any questions but
um there's nothing else i can really add
okay i know it's a very complex subject
a bit of a minefield but um thank you
very much for that walk through
um in the absence of any questions
before me i
shall note the report and move on to the
next item which will be item 14 which is
general update
to receive a report from grant thornton
llp external auditors that's pages seven
to eight to ninety
so i believe alex is doing this report
alex walling she is thank you chair okay
thank you alex thank you so i'll take
the paper as largely read
um in terms of it's our normal progress
report and sector update so in terms of
progress as of january
uh 2021 um i won't talk about
1920 because i'll cover that in the next
item if that's okay and the annual
didn't matter
just to highlight a couple of things
then on on the page that you got in
front of you
apologies i'm not sure it's page four of
our report anyway
um so in terms of certification of
claims and returns as you know each year
we have to
certify the collect the housing benefits
subsidy claim
that work is currently ongoing and
we aim to get it done i think it's
mid-february at the latest
we have had some delays in getting that
work done partly because of the
um the implications of doing the 1920
local government audits across
across the south west and across the
country as well and i'll talk a bit a
little bit more about some of those
delays when we talk about the annual
audit latter in terms of the other
other items in the progress report so as
i say on that that page we also
highlight we're still doing our um
accountants workshops these will be
virtual for obvious
reasons this year hopefully the finance
team have had
um an invite or certainly have
communications from andy
about those i can see david not doing so
that's good
so hopefully they'll be useful as they
have been previously i appreciate doing
things via
ms teams or zoom is is more is is
difficult
but unfortunately obviously that's
that's the world we're in at the moment
um the other thing i just wanted to
highlight was the valley for money work
for 2021
onwards so we mentioned it briefly on
the progress page but there's a little
bit more later on
in the sector update the national audit
office who obviously oversee
external audit work produce a code code
of audit practice periodically
the last one was actually came into
being in
april 2020 not many changes in the code
apart from around the value for money
work
and the focus of the value for money
work will change slightly
for 2021 onwards it won't be a
conclusion per se
so obviously previously we've had a very
binary
you've got the arrangements in place or
you haven't got the arrangements in
place
this is more of a commentary and it'll
cover we'll have we're required to do a
commentary on the three areas that are
being looked at um
under the vfm arrangements um
so it is a bigger piece of work um and
unfortunately with that will come an
additional fee and we will be discussing
that
in due course with with finance officers
um as i wasn't going to go through the
rest of the
progress report and sector update but
i'm more than happy to
to take questions on any of it
okay you mentioned an additional fee
how much is this additional fee going to
be
um in terms of the value for money work
for 2021
um we're currently collating that at the
moment what we're actually doing is
collating something
to share with psaa so we can have those
early conversations because clearly this
is
this is not an additional fee that's
been levied by grant thornton it's as a
result of
obviously the neos code changing but as
i say it is a bigger piece of work
but so at the moment we're closing that
information which will go to psaa
who um will then take it take it from
there but i suspect if i'm being honest
certainly for 2021 it will mean
conversations as we've had in previous
years between
the chief finance officer and myself and
the manager
as to what that fee might look like
before it goes to psaa
the fee consultation for 21
22 i believe is out or um and that's
actually
a document that you i don't know if
you're aware of i don't know if david's
aware of
um that's on the psa website i would i
think
i haven't personally looked at it but
obviously i have other entities that i
deal with have been started to look at
it
because there are various repercussions
of things like the redmond review
and regulator reports etc which do have
an impact on
on various things including the fees and
obviously the psa
overseas fees um for the whole of the
those entities that are in that
framework contract
we haven't mentioned any figures here
what sort of region is it likely to be
in
i think at this stage around the vfo i
think it's very difficult to say
we're currently um assessing what the
work will actually look like
and then we then actually be able to
work out what the femite
might be and will obviously come back to
you and do course to have those
conversations
you're you're batting it away from me
but we as a council have
got to make some very hard budget
decisions at the moment and like to
covet
and i'm just looking for
a sort of ballpark figure of where you
think it might be are we looking
at a few thousand or much more
substantive figure
i say at the moment we collect what
we're doing is we're working out what
work we're actually required to do under
the new code
and then working out what the theme
might look like i think it would be
inappropriate for me to try and guess
what that thing might look like at this
stage
okay all right um but we're going to
look at the retrospective part of
the audit in the next item so we're just
looking forward from here on in right
do any members of the committee wish to
come
forward with any points that they've
picked up in this um
item
okay right um we'll now move on to item
15 which is the annual audit letter
and i'll hand over back to you alex
again
thank you chair so um again i wasn't
going to go through this on a page by
page basis the annual audit letter as
you will be aware from
previous years is basically a summation
of the work that we've undertaken under
the code for the financial year 2019
20. the idea is that this
brings together all the messages from
previous work
and is a document that you will put on
your website for various stakeholders to
be aware of and to see
we've also shared it with the national
audit office as well
as i say it's very much cribbed on the
audit findings report which came to
i think was the september audit
committee um from recollection
and so i wasn't going to say go through
it in huge amounts of detail what
in effect what the report actually does
is it sets out things like
what work we're expected to do what
materiality levels we're actually
working to
um it specifies that obviously we gave
the opinion on the 27th of november
and we also gave the value for money
conclusion on that same date as well
and we're able to close the audit on
that date
following completion of the wga work
that we're required to do
so since i wasn't going to go through
page by page because i say it's very
much encrypt from the audit finance
report which you've had previously
what i will do is talk about the fees
which is on
which is an appendix a so obviously the
scale fee is set by psaa
um each year um and in that
in our report we've set that out we've
also set out what
our the proposed the additional proposed
audit fee was
at the planning stage which we've
previously shared
with the council and has actually set
out in a little bit more detail
over the page as to what that 7500 is
made
up of and it's a variety of things like
new financial auditing standards it's
uh the requirements of the
regulator which have grown exponentially
over the last few years
around particularly around large
estimates like property plants and
equipment
and pensions figures so we've set those
out
in addition to that obviously working
remotely has had
additional costs for everybody
including obviously us as auditors now
what we sought to do
is actually consider what costs or
haven't we incur as a result of working
remotely and clearly we haven't had
travel and things like that but the
audits have taken longer
and for any of you that have seen the
psaa website
there was an article that was posted
there i think it's the back end of
november beginning in december
which said i think something like 40 45
of audits were delivered by the 30th of
november across the country
showing that a significant number of
audits
weren't actually done by the 30th of
november and that's
obviously across all audit suppliers so
it's not unique to grant thornton
so as i say having doing this work
remotely
and also the requirements particularly
around the regulator and
actually meeting those has led to an
additional
fee which we've specified as 5894 pounds
to be precise
we've come up with a total audit fee
for the audit of 1920. now for those of
you that are on the committee last year
you recall that the process now
is that we've discussed those figures
with
the chief finance officer and then we
have to go to the psaa
for um basically for them to approve
that additional audit fee um i think
i won't put words into david or
councillor hackett's maths
but i think it'd be fair to say that
when we have those conversations around
fee
the council was was not happy about them
and i i do understand why
um and as a result we've taken the um
we've basically handed it over to psaa
for them to
make a decision as to whether those
those additional fees are reasonable or
not
um and so we're waiting for them to hear
back from them for
for this year um that's all i was going
to say on this annual audit letter
but as i say more than happy to take any
questions
um on it okay
um david you'd like to come in
yeah yeah thank you chair um
alex would you have any assessment of
where you think
the audit process will be for the 2021
accounts in terms of time scales and
what kind of
um how you think you'll be able to
deliver
because obviously last time obviously
signing off the accounts i think it was
the 24th of november
it's probably the latest i recall
certainly since i've been here
and it is very late where do you think
the grant fountain will be in resourcing
the audit
to sort of um mitigate that kind of time
frame
i think that's a very fair question
david quite a very reasonable one
um obviously at the moment we don't know
what the deadlines are for local
government accounts
um they could go back to the 31st of
july although i suspect that would be
rather foolish of the the government
department to actually push it back to
that given where we were at the end of
november
um so at the moment we don't actually
know what deadlines we're working to i
think we've assumed internally it's the
30th of september
but as i say that's not being
communicated as far as i'm aware
i think it would be fair to say that we
are still completing a significant
number of 1920 audits
um and then obviously the housing
benefit work which in an ideal world
would have been um
done by the end of november as well and
other grant claims because
some local authorities also have
additional grant claims that we actually
look at will be all be quite small so i
think it would be fair to say and that's
why i think it's a reasonable question
that we do have a backlog of work um
what we're looking at in the moment
is how we can try and mitigate that
one of the things we're talking about
and obviously we can have a longer
conversation david
outside the meeting is about actually
scaling back interim visits
the interim visits are helpful obviously
we have to do some initial planning
because that informs the audit plan
which is an iso
an auditing standard requirement um
but we there are some things that we've
been doing interims just to make life
easier both for your finance team but
also for us
doing them at interim rather than
waiting to the final accounts but
actually sometimes that isn't the most
efficient way of actually doing the
audit
because we end up almost sometimes
having to duplicate or trying to
reconcile back what we've audited at the
interim stage with what we do at the
final account stage
so we're looking to try and push that
back into the final council audit
at the moment we're working that through
as to what that might look like
we've had the um the deadlines for the
nhs accounts so we know what we're
working to in terms of nhs and that
those deadlines have slipped um slightly
to what they were pre-covered
so i think the nhs recognizes that both
itself
and auditors are still playing catch up
in terms of
um the account side of things um so as i
say we're working through what the
figures might what it might all look
like and what we'll actually need to do
over the next few months and then we'll
be having those conversations
i think i think we all recognize this is
going to be a very difficult year
um and i think you know being honest
um whether we'll get everything
delivered by the end of september i
think is
is a moot point at this moment in time
um
because there is you know there is quite
a lot of work to get through over there
certainly over the next
the coming months and we don't know what
things are going you know they're going
to look like what's going to come out of
the woodwork that perhaps we're not
aware of
um and i think it'd be safe to say that
the likelihood of remember
can continue to work remotely is pretty
high
um certainly this the firm's stance at
the moment is that we should all be
clearly working at home not going out to
clients um
and the only exception i think is stock
takes which doesn't really apply to
local government anyway
so um so i think that's a fair summation
of where we're at at the moment
okay you mentioned about the interim
audit and that's one of the things i was
going to raise
um i've got a question here are we going
to get one
from what what i've just heard it's
going to be
much streamlined but would you just like
me
would you like to clarify to me what was
done in the past
and what you're anticipating doing as an
interim audit
so working that through at the moment
there's a certain amount of work that we
have to do
at the planning and interim stage in
order to decide to pull together the
audit plan which is say uh mentioned it
was a is an auditing standards
requirement
um that we pulled together an audit plan
for the end obviously bring it to
yourselves as those charged with
governments
so we have to do a minimum amount of
work to actually fulfill that
in the past at the interim what we've
also done is a certain amount of
substantive testing
so we might have looked at things like
creditor payments
journals we would have walked through
the key financial systems and
things like that and obviously the value
for money was work we would have started
as well as sort of as a separate stream
so that that's what we would have done
previously and we would have reported
the findings of
that work to yourselves as part of our
progress reports previously
um what we're looking at at the moment
is what capacity we do have
um and then we can actually consider how
much of that substantive testing
we can actually do at the interim stage
or actually whether we're going to have
to say
we're going to have to do some of that
substantive testing at the final account
stage
when we come back in later on and as i
say sometimes that's actually more
efficient
but clearly what we need to do is have
those conversations with the finance
team as to
what can we get done where should we
focus our attentions
are your staff around and have those
sort of logistical conversations
what concerns me is that we are if you
like an agency for dwp and we've got
about 13 million pounds passing through
us
i would be more concerned if i was an
auditor at looking at things like
that than trying to find out what our
property estate is valued at
because we don't have a chief executive
who is getting a bonus
because he's managed to increase the
value of our estate or anything like
that
it's purely to see
are the machinery is the machinery
running well
are there any problems if there is any
evidence of fraud
you are testing it you're giving us a
snapshot
you know our is our accounts department
fit for purpose
things like that and i
am very very concerned that
the housing benefit or audit is just so
far behind and it's such a major issue
and from what i can see the letter
that's been sent into us
today is not a reflection on this
council but a reflection of grant
thornton
how far behind actually are you with it
in months so sorry i'm not actually sure
which letter to it
to europe okay
how far are we behind in that work or
how far are you behind in that work
because we're not as a council
so the deadline for the um the housing
benefit work this year was extended by
gwp to the end of january i believe
we've asked for an extension to i think
it's
well no actually we haven't asked the
extension we've asked officers to answer
that extension
to the 9th of february i believe i'm not
sure there's only responses come back
yet
um confirmed alex it's been confirmed
today brilliant okay i have not i've not
had
not seen that as yet because i've been
in order committees myself all day
so that's literally nine days after the
deadline so i think it'd be fair to say
we are we are behind
um but actually we you know envisaging
getting it done by
that extended deadline which is to say
is in you know the
dwp have given us um all auditors
the chance to actually ask for an
extension recognizing
the impact that kovid has had on us
i mean you also mentioned can i just
could you i think you sort of had two
questions in one there so that yes
yeah then the initial question was
around um our role
so our role our role is really about
giving an opinion
on the accounts and looking for material
misstatement and that's what our focus
will be
i take your points about the additional
grants and that may be when we come to
actually audit some of the
um the grants coming in and going out as
it were
um if they're material we will obviously
be looking at um what the arrangements
are
and actually doing some substantive
testing on it
i absolutely understand what you're
saying around you know property plans
and equipment and the valuations
and i also share your frustrations that
actually
to joe public out there that they
probably don't really care what the
council house is actually worth or your
headquarters is worth or what the car
parks are worth
unfortunately our regulator the
financial reporting council do
they do care and that's why so much of
our focus
over the last few years has been around
those big
estimates in your accounts around
property plant and equipment valuations
and pensions liabilities because they're
too big
potentially manipulating figures that
are that could be manipulated
obviously there's no evidence on based
on the work that we've done previously
at torres that that would be the case
and i don't think i think we've always
assessed the culture
at torridge as being unlikely that such
manipulation would happen
however as i say the regulator does not
share that view and there is an
expectation that we do
quite a lot of work in those particular
areas
i i still haven't quite got a grip from
the answer you've given me as to what
the the value of the
in the interim audit will be
work-wise you know we we have
a contract between grant thornton and
the council
to produce a quality audit
now i'll let david come and explain the
parts here so david if you come in
uh it's not really to come in and
explain it's just really just to make an
observation it's
it's on the 26th of january and as of
yet we don't have a date for the interim
audit i think given that
it's highly unlikely that the interim
audit can can cover up much more than
perhaps the statutory requirements alex
i don't want to put words into your
mouth in terms of the audit planning
i don't really see much fresh prospect
of doing any
what we'd normally do which is a
reasonable degree of substantive
transactional testing in the time frame
that we've got
i'm meeting with oshie and andrew who
are from grant fountain tomorrow to
i've almost looked backwards at the
audit that was and have some discussions
but given that
we haven't got any dates in for an
interim audit now uh we're nearly at the
end of january
i've you know and the ca and the finance
perhaps very busy on other matters as
well
kovitz kind of related i don't see
really that we're going to be doing any
what i'd call an intra-audit to be
honest i think you'd be really
completing
the statutory elements which are really
going to be the audit planning alex i
don't want to put words into your mouth
i think you could be right david and i
think once we've made that assessment of
how
what capacity we've actually got we can
then determine where we've
we focus that um that capacity to make
sure we
hit the high risk areas um and um
you know as i say the interim audits it
might be that we end up having to slip
some of that uh that detailed
substantive testing
until the year end unfortunately um
it is semantics i know councillor
hackett but actually your contract is
with psaa it's not actually with grant
thornton
yes okay that is a moot point and i take
it
but um you know i'm i'm here
or this committee is here to make sure
we have a robust audit
delivered in time because if time
drags on and we don't get it in time we
can have problems and
you know dare i mention patisserie
valerie i
i know there is an issue there that is
at the moment going to court over the
200 million for grant thornton
but something wasn't spotted and i'm
certainly not on my watch
going to let things slip although i have
the utmost confidence
in the staff at torridge but
we've got to make sure that we meet our
deadlines
and have a professional service from our
auditors
and at the moment it's the first time
i've seen
the delays in my tenure of what
coming up to six years as chairman of
the audit committee
that we're having all these delays and i
hear what you say about covid but
is the issue staff retention at grant
thornton is that part of it
i think it's a whole range of issues i
think i think staff retention
at um so there's been various pieces of
work
being done around i think red the
redmond review
touches on it but actually um
people don't really want to do public
sector audit anymore so
you know i've done it for dare i say 30
years which ages me
um but you know actually people don't
want to do it anymore they want to do
other things and so we do
i think you know people of my generation
we stuck around and we did a job for 20
30 years
people have the young people coming
through they don't they want to move on
they train
they move on they want to move into
industry they want to do different
things
and i think that's just unfortunately to
a certain extent a
fact of life so i think that is part of
the issue
um but i think covert has had a massive
effect on um
on on well on all of us and actually it
has worked you know
the fact that it's not just so as i say
if you look at the psaa website they're
um their publication that talks about
the delays in
the audited accounts it talks about all
the suppliers i don't think it names
names but all of the suppliers
so i don't think it is just unique to
grant thornton
about some of the delays okay i
appreciate that but
your predecessor geraldine she would
keep me more up to date about what was
going on either with a phone call or an
email
and we did not have any issues
of the magnitude we have now and yet i
get radio silence from grant thornton
you know mark barkley was good at
picking up the phone putting an email
out
um and i would like to know
where things are rather than waking up
to some nasty surprises to see that
we have major issues that
we're falling behind and i do have an
unease that
it appears that we're going to get less
work
for a greater fee and that concerns me
because
you know we're looking for value for
money as a council and i'm sure you've
heard all these comments before
from other councils but we certainly
don't want torridge lagging behind
and i have made the point before and i
will rest that there
if any members of the committee want to
come in um i will throw it open to the
floor
otherwise we will note the report that
you have given us
and i see no hands raised so thank you
very much indeed for your
report alex and we move on to item 16
which is the forward plan and that is on
page 108.
so i'm i'm putting you back on
um alex or do you
wish andrew to take this item
i'm not sure this is for alex to do is
it um
yeah external auditor's page 108 forward
plan no there's
no it's um
i thought it might be external audit
planned but it is just
our audit plan as a committee okay it's
just right
just what's on the agenda for the end of
march basically
too not a problem right
okay i'm reading off my
okay so item 17 exclusive
the public the chair to move that the
public be excluded for the remainder of
the meeting
because of the likely disclosure of
exempt information as defined in section
12a
of the local government act 1972. so i'd
like to propose that from the chair i'm
looking for a seconder
i'll second it thank you very much
claire
so i'll go back to kirsty and if you'd
like to take the recorded vote please
thank you chair councillor craigie for
councillor hackett for councillor heppel
four councillor hudson
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you so if you'd like to turn